hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
and unless there's been a coup I'm Dave
Reuben I've got Liane tweetIn and Jena
grad with me let's get to it
all right George Bush george w bush he's
back people he was interviewed by ABC's
Jonathan Karl and he's chiming in or not
so chiming in kinda on some stuff let's
take a look at the first clip I saw a
journalist in Zambia asked you about gay
marriage and whether it is compatible
with Christian values and you had an
interesting response I shouldn't be
taking a spin I met that I wasn't going
to answer the question then and I'm not
going to answer it now in terms of the
political question about whether or not
you know I just don't want to wait back
in the debate I'm out of politics but I
met it's very important for people not
to be overly critical as someone else
until you've examined your own heart
alright I like that quote I want to get
it right I shouldn't be taking a speck
out of someone else's eye when I have a
log in my own is that a subtle gay joke
I'm not so sure lady what do you think
about this because it seems to me that
you know he gets out and now he's
starting to chime back in on things but
still just won't jump on the game man I
mean just go for it already I think you
know I totally respect his view of not
responding he isn't the president
anymore and I'm sure they asked him for
the interview and they want to ask him
about that because it's his party and
what does he think I'm okay with that
and I think the end that last quote he
was probably referring to Dick Cheney
who has a gay daughter and you know so
I'm saying I think he's going look most
Americans are very personal in their
politics and you go and you you vote
your politics when you go to the voting
booth and a lot of times you don't know
what your neighbor thinks or what
they're gonna vote on so I think he's
like you know what to each his own and
I'm out of politics I don't need to
answer that question and I respect that
a defense of George Bush in the Young
Turks to do how about that do you think
the president what to do you mean do you
think the former presidents that they
should just stay out of every
well I don't think they should stay out
if they have an opinion go for it but I
think we're all so used to it's been
long enough that w hasn't been in the
office that we're used to him saying
something stupid there our coffee table
books about it there's all kinds of you
know funny little things and memes and
all the stuff that everything that comes
out of his mouth
is complete chaos and crazy [ __ ] I
mean it is so refreshing for him to be
like look I'm out of politics and to
each his own and all these wonderful
things that we could have used you know
very quiet
he's been very quiet his retirement
which has been great he's like you know
what I'm out I don't I don't need to to
talk about things yeah he doesn't
exactly roll back into this was there a
little piece of it that's a little
disingenuous because you know it was him
when he was being reelected that made
gay marriage like a real wedge issue to
talk about it now I mean why are you why
are you if he wants to keep it personal
why are you mad that he doesn't want to
say it out loud I don't know that oh man
it just seems to me like get on the
right side you know if he supported gay
marriage I'd be even more pissed cuz I'd
be like where was this guy just made a
difference right now all of a sudden
it's okay for you know screw you well
that's an interesting point because
somebody like Dick Cheney the second he
was out suddenly oh now he backs gay
marriage everybody everybody the second
they're not in it anymore how about our
vice president now he's probably written
a few chapters you get this like crazy
old uncle George vibe and it's like you
know he's he's an elf
he's elderly now kind of you just go sit
in the corner
he comes up as more likeable now for
sure but let's let's watch this other
clip so he was also discussing the NSA
tactics and what happens once you become
president and he was sort of backing
President Obama on this take listen are
you surprised the President Obama's kept
in place so many of your
counterterrorism programs including was
he criticized as a candidate
I think the president got into the Oval
Office and realized the dangers to the
United States and he's acted in a way
that he thinks is necessary to protect
the country protecting the country is
the most important job of the presidency
ok so I can kind of back what the ladies
are saying about the gay marriage thing
and he's trying not to jump in on it
this thing though seems really awful to
me because everyone runs on an idea and
then the second they become president
they change everything they oh now I
have some new information and now I have
to say some other things is it why do we
believe anyone that's running for
anything ever right if you look at
Obama's track record on everything that
he promised when he became president I
think he's done like maybe a half of one
thing so he's been very terrible on that
record if you look at the facts whether
I'm an Obama supporter or not I'm not
gonna say that but I'm just saying if
you look at the facts what he said so
right so even though they stuff for
example he said all we're gonna do this
responsibly he's continued on the wars
okay I think he realizes things aren't
shutting down Guantanamo things aren't
as easy as what they say and the
platform that everybody wants to hear
let's let's let's a minute politicians
say what you want to hear so people go
oh yeah we robbed and a vote for that
and then nothing happens but I think
when it comes to NSA look we all know
we've been surveilling each other it's
been happening I mean the Cold War
people just said yesterday oh you know
what there's still some towers up that
the Russians have you know why
everybody's spying on each other
everybody has technology everybody knows
you sure has it gone too far maybe in in
you know saying it's the defense of the
country sure it probably has stopped a
lot of things so there is a fine line I
don't know I'm not president I know it's
a really damn difficult job but is that
is that a valid excuse because they all
run the saying one thing and then the
excuse just come I mean even Bill Maher
was giving Obama a pass on this saying
well you find out stuff you know the
same thing that Bush said I was hoping
for like more of like a hot chick like
point counterpoint but I really am I
really do because that's exactly I think
when when you're running and you haven't
been in the president before you are the
people's voice and then once you cross
that line you're the president now it's
kind of you against them because you
know things they will
don't want that list like it still isn't
that why their hair turns gray after
like two weeks because they're too old
like you know age right the lizard
people are among us and they're like Oh
everything that we don't know so all of
a sudden they're not speaking for us
anymore
right so we're all admitting freely that
when they're speaking for us before they
become president that it's all a lie
right I mean is that pretty much what
we're saying that it's sort of willful
ignorance just a lot of things in
politics money lobbyists there's a lot
of things that come about when you
actually get into the office and then
you go well I would like to pass this
but then I'm not going to get this this
and this done or pushed through if I
don't get them to work with me so it's a
lot more difficult
look all politicians across the board
are liars and they know they say things
that they will never be able to fulfill
and democracy yeah so final point on
this should obey uh
actually be a little annoyed at george w
bush because when he says nice things
about him that can't be good for Obama's
ratings you know or should be like I'll
take it I have a quick anecdotal support
of what you just said I just live in a
super bad neighborhood if for a long
time and every a couple nights a week a
cop would roll up next to me be like hey
do you want me to you know escort you
home and it's like get the [ __ ] out of
here like I'm ruining my reputation of
them in Africa like they're buddies and
my mom is like yeah
you